after days of uncertainty doctors say
u.s president donald trump no longer has
any covid19 symptoms
trump returned to the white house
earlier in the week after hospital
treatment
saying he felt good and that fellow
americans should not let kovid 19
dominate their lives
with the presidential election just
weeks away trump is presenting himself
as a coroner superhero
and sometimes appearing to show contempt
for the more than two hundred thousand
americans
who've lost their lives in the pandemic
so unto the point we ask
trump's mysterious recovery will kovid
decide
the u.s election
[Music]
well thanks so much for joining us here
on the show where my guests are
yulia fisher who argues that trump
prefers the simplistic to the scientific
but that means nothing to the virus also
with us is rachel tells him freud from
the german marshall fund who says
trump's strange corona show as she puts
it
hurts more than it helps but it is still
a very
tight race and a warm welcome to william
bluecroft us native and dw news reporter
he believes that trump's critics would
be wise to temper their sharden freuder
nothing has taken the president down yet
[Music]
interesting statements thank you all
three for being here lovely
uh rachel thompson friday first question
first impression
you talk about trump's strange corona
show what is your response your personal
response to that show to that
presentation that we've seen
um yeah i mean it's it's a
insane sort of movie
type of uh type of in engineering in
in in the middle of a real pandemic and
as you said in the beginning i mean 200
000 people have died
and then he you know creates this uh
crazy
film that's like a like an advertisement
it's like the theater of the absurd
it is very much like the theater of the
absurd with the background
of a very very serious illness and a
country that has not managed
um to to handle it correctly okay we
agree
that it's a theater of the absurd kind
of a performance william what is he
trying to achieve donald trump with it
i mean that he's a superman that he's
able that he's able to dominate
this virus this virus is not a very big
deal
just like he's always been saying all
along and it should be
very importantly noted that this virus
might not be such a big deal if
everyone in america is able to get the
kind of health care and the kind of
access to
medicines that he's been able to get um
but this can
the coronavirus is costing average
americans depending on their health
insurance plan up to 70 thousand dollars
in
most severe cases this is something that
president trump doesn't have to deal
with or does anyone in government
because
they get government health care and
the whole show that he's putting on at
the moment is this is is it driven by
gut
instinct or is it is there a strategy
behind it
i mean i i maybe those two things are
the same thing his gut and
strategy i mean he is a showman we know
this from his years at the apprentice
at the apprentice and miss universe he
really thrives in this kind of
showmanship like atmosphere
we're testing the limits now of how much
he can bend
reality the white house the trump white
house has been very much a boy who cries
wolf kind of situation and even if
they are telling you the truth now even
if trump really is better
we just don't know there's absolutely no
reason for us to believe
what he's telling us and that's
extremely damaging for both his
supporters and his opponents to know
what's really going on yeah do we know
don't we know julia i mean you're a
doctor and a journalist all in one when
you know with your doctor's eye what are
you seeing what bill of health would you
give donald trump at the moment
yeah even as a doctor it's hard to tell
if you're not there
because i mean he did get medications
that's
actually reserved for severe cases and
if he wasn't severely sick then why did
he get them
maybe because he said just give me
everything that you have
i want it all right and that is quite
realistic um
it's difficult to say also we don't see
him all the time he might be resting in
bed and later coming out
um pretending to be the superhero we
don't we just don't really know but what
is your guess is he going to be able to
fight the campaign to the end
i mean he's got weeks ahead it's going
to be tough it's going to be tough
um but it totally depends on how he
recovers now if he really is
fine and if he does get a negative test
because that is something that i as a
doctor
find very difficult to see how right now
being infective
he runs around without a mask and i mean
he does need to get
a negative test before he can go back
into debates and things
um so i think that should really happen
before he
gets back to business as usual maybe
he gets it done rachel yeah i think um
we don't know yet i mean we'll know in
the next week probably
if he is in fact more seriously ill than
he's letting on
he's going to hit a wall and for example
the debate right
there's no way he can first of all get a
negative test second of all stand up
there for 90 minutes
um if he's not actually fit if he can if
the debate happens and if he actually
shows up then
then i think we know okay he really did
recover quickly
but again he recovered you know maybe
also quickly because he had
every medicine even experimental
medicines that others can't get
and he was lucky okay well donald trump
certainly appeared to be
pumped up when he returned to the white
house let's listen to a little bit of
what he
had to say don't let it dominate don't
let it take over your lives
don't let that happen we have the
greatest country in the world
we're going back we're going back to
work we're going to be out front
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger to it but i had to do it
i stood out front i led
[Music]
rachel thousand friends the president
the president said don't let covet
dominate don't let it take over your
lives uh
are americans likely to be uh inspired
by that messaging
or comforted or what definitely not
comforted uh some very few might be
inspired by that message but let's look
at michigan for a second
this was a statement i'm from michigan
and this is a state that
donald trump crucially won in the last
election after it having gone to
democrats in the previous
three elections um and michigan was the
third
worst hit state in the beginning of the
corona crisis so when i talk to people
who live you know in the suburbs of
detroit or around they they need two
hands
to count the people they know who were
very seriously ill some of whom died
so this show is not working with them
it's not going to work
but of course we have to remember that
even if polls are showing both
nationwide and
in crucial swing states that a majority
two-thirds whatever the number might be
might be
finding this completely unrealistic and
not buying what trump is saying we don't
trump doesn't necessarily need that many
votes as we saw in 2016. he doesn't even
need the popular vote
to be able to win and that's the big
question is yes
the tide is against donald trump yes the
numbers are in favor of joe biden are
they enough democrats have been saying
since the convention actually since
kamala harris made her first speech as
the vice presidential pick
that democrats need voters to come out
in droves it's not enough just to have a
win
they need a landslide victory not only
because of how the math works with the
electoral college but just to make a
a definitive statement to trump and all
the supporters no the reality is on our
side
it's not going to be enough for there
just to be a technical win
that biden and the democrats need a real
hard win
you know maybe akin to what we saw in
rate with reagan in in his re-election
in the 80s
and i i i in one of the statements that
i made earlier in the show i i indicated
that perhaps there's a sense of
among many americans they feel there's a
contempt for their
for their lives and their struggles from
the president is that gonna
is that going to help to create a mood
that will push the democrats in
to the size of voting that you say they
need i mean that's certainly what
democrats are hoping for they
immediately made this not about donald
trump they made this about health care
they made this about health care access
uh they made this about the seriousness
of the virus and that if donald trump
the most looked after man in the world
can get coronavirus than anyone can that
is still very serious
really trying to use donald trump to
their advantage to make their very point
the question is the united states is
very much an aspirational country that's
america's mojo is its aspirational
aspects that anything is possible
regardless of the facts you can go
bankrupt
a thousand times as we've seen donald
trump do it doesn't matter the man is
still president the man became
he put his mind to it and he became
president there's nothing more american
than that
idea and the question is are voters
going to look at the reality and look at
these 210
000 deaths and all of the other messes
that the united states is in social
unrest
cities on fire forests on fire massive
hurricanes the economic crisis are they
going to look at all those things
or are they going to listen to donald
trump and listen to this in his kind of
reverse optimism the best is yet to come
stick with
us anything is possible and try to dream
big
which of those americas are voters going
to see or enough voters as i just said
enough voters going to see to tip the
election one way or the other
julia your thoughts on that um i think
well what trump has always been doing
and what he's still trying to do
is um he really emotionalizes everything
he says and he really
makes two groups of the people um it's
it's
the ones that are with him and his
components and um
he he really gets uh this group dynamic
going
and he emotionalizes what he says and um
is all about
we can do this together and those are
the bad guys we have to fight together
and i think that is something that's
emotionally working
with the people unfortunately it's the
he plays with
the emotions the people have with their
fear um
and and with an attempt to find somebody
they can blame
in order to to know how to act in that
situation and i think that is working
for him
and politics are human and humans are
emotional so this works
well in what uh almost appears to be a
self-destructive mode president
trump has sparked further controversy by
blocking talks with the democrats on a
coronavirus stimulus package that could
have eased the
misery for many americans the kind of
misery that his whole approach to the
pandemic has brought with it
so far trump's response to the corona
pandemic has left more than seven
million people infected
and over two hundred thousand dead in
the us
at the start of the epidemic this is
what he said
looks like by april you know in theory
when it gets a little warmer it
miraculously goes away hope that's true
instead of listening to experts he
suggests
bizarre forms of treatment supposing we
hit the body
with a tremendous uh whether it's
ultraviolet or just
very powerful light then i said
supposing you brought the light inside
the body you can which you can do either
through the skin or
uh in some other way right and then i
see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute
he refused to wear a mask during his
campaign appearances
and at the televised debate in september
he mocked his challenger joe biden for
doing so i don't have
i don't wear mess like him every time
you see him he's got a mask he could be
speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
biden the coward versus trump the
superman
will this strategy work that's the
question
trump the superman biden the coward is
is it going to work the strategy
no uh i think he was maybe on track to
have a little bit of success with that
and then he got infected himself i mean
it's it's really the game changer in the
trump
narrative uh thus far i mean he has to
do now
because he is he isn't invulnerable he
is
we have learned that we have discovered
that we now know it
apparently for a fact yeah and and joe
biden's not a coward jobidenus may be
smart
because he's not the one who's infected
i mean you know not to be crude but
the attack is so clear if you can't if
the president cannot even protect
himself
how is he supposed to protect the people
julia how do you
it might be instructive to compare
donald trump uh with his uh his
contempt again i'm going to use that
word for for doctors for experts for
specialists and
somebody like angela merkel who is
herself a scientist you know this uh
you you described it as a systematic
science against uh
superstition almost yeah yeah i mean
what he's doing
is it's it's so difficult to watch how
his
scientific um advisors tell him one
thing and
he does another he politicizes the the
measures against the coronavirus
in a wrong way and gets the people not
to wear the mask
to make sure they are the real trump
followers that's really dangerous
and reckless and yeah
i i don't see how how people who also
have a scientific
um belief can cannot see that it's
difficult to watch
well joe biden for his part has made it
clear that he wants corona to dominate
the election here's what he had to say
on that front
here's what i'll do as president number
one
call on every single american to wear a
mask when they're around other people
outside their households
wear a mask when you're on public
transportation
if i can say something here this is not
about freedom
it's about patriotism
is joe biden going to succeed in
maintaining
the corona story as the central
narrative of this election battle
i mean we've had so many huge
earth-shattering issues in this election
year starting with
trump's impeachment then the pandemic
the economic fallout the social
injustice all the natural disasters
trump's taxes have come out finally come
to light or at least part of them
the debate debacle any one of these
things would upend an election and
change the result we're dealing with all
of these things at once it seems
difficult to imagine how coronavirus
won't be the big topic
through the election but who knows what
these next two or three weeks are going
to bring you know time goes fast
you yourself have pointed out he's still
you know in a boxing metaphor he's still
on his feet he's still fighting how does
he manage that
uh because he's donald trump and he has
you know he was once interviewed he was
once interviewed uh
by a by a photographer for pbs and he
was asked you know how do you manage you
know this this storm around you and
donald trump said i am the storm
he really relishes in this chaos he
likes creating chaos and controlling the
chaos
and you know his you might think his
policies and his his being president is
despicable but
from that point of view he's very
effective let me just stick with you for
a second because
i know that you have said that uh it's
not just the president who is ill but
the presidency that is ill
that is sick that's right you know
donald trump wants to make everything
about himself always
and for liberals or his opponents people
around the world people here in europe
who are laughing right now or saying i
told you so or
even maybe even rejoicing in the fact
that donald trump got coronavirus after
denying it for so long or playing it
down for so long
that playing into his hands about making
it all about trump
when a president is sick the presidency
is sick the presidency is limited to
what it can do the president is just
the the individual filling that role
it's of course a much
broader office of advisors and executive
branch and
we see now that high-level uh military
officials are in quarantine
it takes its toll on a country and if
you do care about what we call the
liberal world order the post-war order
if we care about
you know a strong stable united states
working with europe
then you need a stronger you want a
strong stable
president and a presidency so we've seen
this in the past you know with woodrow
wilson with
fdr you know major major events happened
they're sick they haven't really
informed their their advisors or their
the people who might take over for them
and we've just gotten lucky in these
instances that there have been strong
competent people
around a weak or sick president to take
over for things
we might not always have that um you
know luck in history has been on
america's side for a long time
we don't know how long that's going to
last and pursuing this thought still
further rachel
uh first of all began we began with
perhaps the president himself is ill or
sick perhaps the presidency is illogic
a prestigious german newspaper wrote a
couple of days ago
america is sick yeah i mean of course
literally first of all america is sick
um the the numbers are bad and getting
worse
um and the fact that it hasn't been able
to deal more effectively
you know like germany for example this
is not a sign of a
healthy country the fact that you know
someone like
donald trump first of all is president
and second of all that we cannot believe
that we would be wrong to uncritically
believe the information coming out of
the white house this is a sign of
sickness
we should be able to believe the
information coming out of the white
house but sadly
we cannot can america be a resurgent
society a resurgent country politically
medically in terms of the health of its
people can it shrug all this off
i think it's there's a lot of work to do
it's it's gonna be a tough time
and things there's a lot of things that
have to to happen
concerning the the pandemic right now
but also concerning the health system
um having also um
the also poor workers um
getting in and health insurance and
things like that so there's really
an economically there has a lot of to be
done so it's a long way
there's a lot of work to do we've see
we've seen in the
uh the vice presidential debate taking
place in utah
uh mike pence on the one hand uh let's
listen to what he had to say
first and then we'll see what the
challenger had to say
that from the very first day president
donald trump has put the health of
america first
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
president donald trump did what no other
american president had ever done
and that was he suspended all travel
from china the second largest economy
in the world what do you make julia of
that defense of
president trump and his strategy it's a
nice try
but there were so many other things that
went wrong
and the people who who actually brought
the the virus within into the country
did not come from china but from europe
and um or they did also come from europe
and he didn't stop that
on time and he never he he keeps
downplaying how dangerous the virus is
he did that in the start which is why he
didn't he didn't
lock down the country early enough when
he chose to lock down he didn't
use the time to prepare the country for
the reopening
he reopened too early and this is
that's why he's still running after the
pandemic
and he keeps politicizing the measures
against the corona virus and that's just
terribly dangerous
okay well mike pence was up against
kamala harris california senator let's
listen to what she had to say
the american people have witnessed what
is
the greatest failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country
and here are the facts 210 000 dead
people in our country
in just the last several months over
seven million people who have contracted
this disease
one in five businesses closed
we're looking at frontline workers who
have been treated
like sacrificial workers
rachel like uh some like myself you set
your alarm clock to be
up early in the morning to watch the
debate what did you make of that and the
debate in general
uh i mean the debate in general was it
was a bit like
a traveling in time back to 2015
you know was a return to sort of
standard american political debates
which are also not great right there's a
lot of running around the truth not
answering
questions um you know brutal attacks
that sort of stay on the surface so
this was you know by no means some kind
of shining example of democracy but
wow was it refreshing after the uh
presidential debate i think they both
uh gave pretty good performances did
quite well
and uh what we see you know among other
things is
pence is so much better at defending
trump and defending trump's policies
than trump himself is
well we should be careful not to trip
over the bar that we've set so low for
ourselves
um you know pence himself just has
described himself as rush limbaugh on
decaf when he was a far
right uh conservative radio show host so
he has that calm fact that he's often
forgotten about pence yeah yeah yeah
yeah
right kamal harris was the attorney
general and mike pence was a
conservative radio show talk shows and
not even in a very uh huge
not even the biggest of markets so we
should definitely as you say debates in
general in the united states are not
really a model and we shouldn't we
should be mindful of where we keep our
our bar i think when it comes to the
trump administration these claims about
you know battling the virus and taking
it seriously
on a number of fronts the trump
administration i think intentionally
confuses instincts with outcomes
a lot of their instincts are correct you
know needing to be tough around china
needing to get you know nato to you know
shape up and be more of an equal partner
with the united states
um and general relations general
relations with the united states and
other parts
of the world trying to bring back
manufacturing with a lot in a lot of
these uh working-class blue-collar towns
that have just been decimated over the
last several decades
the instincts are right that doesn't
necessarily mean the outcomes and the
way they choose to pursue those policies
are very good as we saw with the trade
war most it's american consumers and
american companies
uh that are paying these tariffs for
example and they'll they'll talk about
their instincts
but it's their outcomes as you rightly
pointed out yeah okay you block travel
from china what about all the other
things you didn't do or denied
okay the biden bandwagon is racing a
pace
forward to victory it appears you could
almost say at this point in time
what could upset the bandwagon
himself as we've seen joe biden can
often often be his own worst enemy
he's benefited from the coronavirus by
having fewer opportunities to put his
foot in his mouth
if something really big happens that
takes all of our attention away from
the coronavirus again that's probably
good for trump
um i mean i hope that's gonna have to be
big and bad so i hope nothing like that
happens but that would certainly
upend things yeah i also think only if
if you get that attention away from the
corona virus and maybe back to economics
or something that could help
but i don't really see that coming
unless unless the long wished upon
vaccine comes out which might magically
appear as trump keeps
pushing and pushing pressuring his the
fda and the cdc
to do yeah who's going to be the next
president of the united states for
murray
[Laughter]
i mean that's such a simplistic question
but i'd like to see we thought it was
simple before
2016 behind the decision or the the the
the guess you're going to give me yeah
so you know we all know now that
guessing is very dangerous
the numbers look very good for biden the
storyline that i think is going to
continue until election day which is
kovid and the circle around trump
potentially getting sicker and sicker
is not good for trump therefore i do
think
biden it's biden's race to lose at this
point
julia i also think so because uh
trump has been trying to push away the
coronavirus as long as he could whenever
he could and right now he can't
anymore and that's his biggest problem
and that's
i think that's going to be the weakness
that will cost him the win
there's definitely no way i'm going to
be put down on record for saying one way
or the other
i think what you said was was very much
right on there are two points to make
we probably most likely will not have a
result on election night
um and trump is probably gonna do
everything in his power to sow doubt
into the results so even if biden looks
like he's winning and factually is
winning
there might still be a lot of doubt
swirling around in the days and weeks to
follow and i think the bigger point
is to remember you mentioned earlier how
america is sick i think it's important
to remember that trump
to continue with this metaphor is a
symptom not a cause
that that you know when the president is
your guy
you're very happy that he has all the
power and when he's not your guy
uh you want that power taken away and
donald trump
really has ripped off the band-aid and
underneath has a lot of problems that
have been festering the united states
for a very long time that only now
happen to be
affecting or being felt by a majority of
americans that have been felt by other
groups of americans for a very very long
time i think those are bigger issues
that the united states has to deal with
he wallows in disruption
he's a master of disruption
i think it's been done no i think he's
been one of the constant uh
the constant themes of the recent years
under trump and i think it could be
what we're going to be looking at in the
next is he
we're gonna have to leave it there we've
been talking about the us election about
trump about
uh the pandemic and how it's uh having
an impact impact whether it will
continue to have an impact
thanks for joining us if you've enjoyed
the show as much as i have come back
next week
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you